-Here's how the game works.
I have a stack of cards
right here.
Each card has the name
of a TV show written on it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now, don't grab it yet. Okay.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-As soon as you look at
the card, you have 5 seconds
to describe what the show is
about the best way you can
and try to make me
guess which show it is.
You can't use any words in
the title of the show
or say any of the
actors's names.
You're just describing the plot
of the show in 5 seconds.
Sound good?
-This is like "Taboo."
I'm good at this. Okay.
-You're good at it? Okay.
Here we go. You go.
Let's put 5 seconds
on the clock.
-Where's the clock?
-There's the clock.
You go first. Ready?
-Okay.
-Come on, pal. We got this.
-You're going to do the clock.
-We got this.
-Okay.
-All right. I'll do the clock.
You just give me
5 seconds of a summary.
Here we go.
-Great.
Dragons.
-"Game of Thrones."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was a record. 3 seconds.
Dude, you're really good.
-I told you.
-You're really good at this.
-How good are you, Jimmy?
-Oh, I don't think
I'm that good.
Okay. Gosh, all right.
Here we go. Ready?
5 seconds on the clock.
-Okay.
-Come on. We can do this.
-Kids, '80s, Eleven. She --
-Oh, "Goldblum," "Goldberg,"
"Goldblums."
-Little kids, '80s.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Buzzer ]
Aah!
[ Tuba plays ]
-"Stranger Things."
-Oh! "Stranger Things."
-All right, here you go.
-Little kid, nosebleed.
-I know. I was bad.
I'm warming up.
-Okay.
-All right, now,
look, for this round,
let's make it
a little bit more interesting.
We're only going to
have 3 seconds on the clock.
All right.
-Well, I all ready beat it.
I did 2 seconds, so...
-I know you did it. Here we go.
3 seconds. This should be
easy-peasy for you.
-Okay, ready.
-Come on, Taraji.
-Ooh, that's yours. Okay.
Marry me, bitch!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-What is -- "The Bachelor"?!
Oh, my gosh.
"The Bachelor." Okay.
Yes, I should have guessed that.
[ Both laugh ]
Yes, that is actually
the slogan for next season.
Okay.
-Yes.
-Oh, you are the greatest.
All right. Here we go.
Can I have 3 seconds?
-Oh, God.
-Who lives in
a pineapple under the sea?
-"SpongeBob"!
-Yes!
-Whoo!
-Yes! That was good!
All right, I redeemed myself.
All right.
It's not going to beat
"marry me," but that was great.
All right, here we go.
Now, for this one, let's just
put 1 second on the clock.
That's good. Here we go.
This is the real game. Ready?
Go.
-[ Crying ]
-"This Is Us."
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-That's exactly -- great.
Oh, you're amazing.
Oh, I can't top this.
Okay, here we go.
Whoo! All right.
Stop laughing. Here we go.
All right, 1 second on
the clock for me.
-Oh, God.
-Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-You.
[ Buzzer ]
-"Empire"!
[ Dinging ]
-Yes! Come on. "Empire."
Taraji P. Henson!